WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
AN ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL
START AS SUBCOMMITTEE.
WITHOUT THERE A FEW MONTHS NOW
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE.
THERE ARE SIX ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP FOUR
THIRTY WHITE HOUSE HE HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
THERE ARE TWO ITEMS LIKE CONSENT
COLORED OUT TAKING UP ONLY STOPS
A QUORUM THERE ARE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB. ONE EIGHTY FOUR MORE
LOCK AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO SENATE LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST AUTHOR WE HAVE
CENTER NIELSEN [inaudible]
WELL.
WORKING ON THIS FOR SOME TIME.
THERE'S BEEN THE MANY YEARS HERE
KIND OF AN ELECTED CLASS BULLIES
AND THEY CAPTION FLOYD.
IN MY ROLE.
OPPORTUNITY. TO PARTICIPATE.
IN A FOR MORE FAIR MINDED WAY.
AND WHAT IT WOULD DO IS SET UP
AN ARBITRATION.
PROCESS.
IF.
AN EMPLOYEE FILES A GRIEVANCE
NOW.
THESE GRIEVANCES ARE ROUTINELY
DENIED.
SO IT'S ALMOST A MOCKERY.
SAYS THEY HAVE NO OPTIONS OTHER
THAN GO TO THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD OR THE COURT [inaudible]
AND THAT'S TIME CONSUMING IT
AFFECTS CERTAINLY THE EMPLOYEE.
DOESN'T REALLY HELP THE STATE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
TO OPTIMIZE THE GRIEVANCE
ROCESS?
ALLOWING THE EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES
TO REQUEST ARBITRATION.
AFTER THEY WOULD NOT A BIG IS
LOST THE NORMAL GRIEVANCE
PROCESS.
AND THAT'S A KIND OF A NORMAL
THING IN STATE GOVERNMENT YEP
EXHAUST ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDIES.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS ADDS A LOSER
PAY MODEL.
THIS IS A FILTER A CONSCIENCE.
ON FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS.
AND ALLOWS THE PARTIES AND GIVE
SOME INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
SERIOUSLY.
CONSIDER RESOLVING THINGS
[inaudible]
IN ARBITRATION.
WE'VE CONTINUED TO WORK WITH
THIS BILL OVER THE YEARS.
END OF CHIEFS A MINOR AND THAT I
THINK SIGNIFICANT.
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT WOULD
NARAL [inaudible]
THE BILL.
AND STOP THE WASTED RESOURCES.
OF THIS CONTINUED.
AND PROTRACTED LITIGATION.
IF THERE'S EVER TO BE A
RESOLUTION.
AND PARTICULARLY TOGETHER.
SOME RECOGNITION. TO THESE
EXPLODED EMPLOYEES.
WHO ARE SO OFTEN FORGOTTEN?
AND KEEP IN MIND.
AND THIS IS KIND OF GOING A
LITTLE BIT AWAY FROM THE BILL
BUT EXPLODED EMPLOYEES OR WHAT I
HAVE CALLED.
KIND OF YOUR YOUR BENCH.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TALENT.
IN SOME AMBITION.
THEY LEARN THEIR JOBS.
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO STEP UP
AND TAKE MORE RESPONSIBILITY.
AND VERY OFTEN THEY PAY A PRICE.
VERY OFTEN THEY GET LESS MONEY.
FOR TAKING THAT EXTRA
RESPONSIBILITY [inaudible]
AND JUST TO SUMMARIZE.
THE EMPLOYEES CAN REQUEST IS
BINDING ARBITRATION.
WHEN A TITLE TO GRIEVANCES BEEN
FILED [inaudible]
CATTLE HR.
AND WHEN THE HAVE GRIEVANCE.
RED AS NOT BEEN RESOLVED AT THE
MULTI REVIEW LEVEL IN OTHER
WORDS EXHAUSTING THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE STEPS.
THEN IT ALLOWS A PROCESS WHEREBY.
HR AN EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION CAN
AGREE O AN IMPARTIAL ARBITRATOR.
THAT ARBITRATION WOULD BE
BINDING WITHIN FORTY FIVE DAYS.
AND THE NON PREVAILING PARTY.
WOULD PAY THE COST.
SURE TO CALL THE BASEBALL STYLE.
RESOLUTION.
BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
I THINK THAT THIS BRING SOME
EQUITY.
AND NO REAL HARM. TO OUR STATE.
EMPLOYEES BARGAINING PROCESS AN
HR.
AND I HAVE WITH THIS TODAY FROM
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU -- FOR BEFORE GOING
FURTHER GOING STEPS QUORUM SINCE
WE DO HAVE ALL MEMBERS PRESENT A
SECTOR CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
COOLEY YOUR COOPER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
OKAY WITH THAT GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE OUR MEMBERS SUPPORT.
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION
SPONSORS OF THE BILL SENATOR
NIELSEN HAS MADE THE CASE WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MAY ARISE.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME'S FORD
CANNELLA ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
LIVES ON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION -- WE REPRESENT
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS AND
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND IT --
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
OF POLICE -- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
THREE CASES IN LITIGATION ONE
WAS A LOCK TIME OR IN THE
SUPREME COURT WHICH THE STATE EN
US HAVE SPENT MILLIONS ON WHICH
COULD HAVE BEEN.
DONE A LONG TIME AGO FOR PENNIES
ON THE DOLLAR.
AND THEN WE HAVE TWO OTHER CASES
APARTMENT AS STATE HOSPITALS
WHICH WERE LITIGATING IS VERY
COURT AGAIN SIMPLE MATTERS THAT.
WE HAD TO LITIGATE AND THE STATE
AND US OR BOWLS -- SPENDING DOES.
THERE'S TONS OF MONEY ON AND AND
IT'S BEEN GONE THE ONE FOUR OR
THE WHAT TIME IS IN ITS ELEVENTH
YEAR OF HEARINGS.
IT WORK M. ELEVEN YEARS AND IT
COULD HAVE BEEN ARBITRATED FROM
DAY ONE AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
OVER MANY YEARS AGO FOR NOT --
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR THIS IS --
WE NEED SOME KIND OF FAIRNESS
WERE WERE WERE -- LIKE IN A OF
OF OF IF THE EMPTY DRUM THAT
SEALED IT BOTH HANDS WE CAN'T --
ARE OF GRIEVANCES ARE ALL ALWAYS
DENIED ALL THE 100% OF CAL HR
FOURTH LEVEL IS DENIED AND I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND I HAVEN'T SEEN -- ONE
GRANTED GRIEVANCE FROM FROM
FOURTH LEVEL SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
WE OR VERY FRUSTRATED SUPERVISOR
FRUSTRATED.
THAT -- THEY CAN'T GET ANYTHING.
DONE HELLO OR IT KNOWLEDGE WHEN
THERE IS A PROBLEM AND OF HI I
DRIVE VOTE BECAUSE WE NEED A WE
NEED.
DO IS TO HAPPEN IT WILL WHAT
WILL HAPPEN I BET THAT WE WON'T
EVEN OUR ARBITRATE ONE TIME.
OF THE OLD THEY'LL FIX IT BEFORE
WE GET TO ARBITRATION BECAUSE
ARBITRATIONS THERE.
JUST TO HAVE IT THERE WILL FIX
THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS THANK YOU.
THE GINGER IN MEMBERS PARKER
EVERY HALF OF THE CORRECTIONS
SUPERVISOR THE QUESTIONS.
AT SIR.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THE PAPER WITH THEIR SYSTEMS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT BOARD
BEFORE THE CONSIDER DEAL SUPPORT
WAS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK SENATOR
NIELSEN [inaudible]
FOR PROBLEM SOLVING.
AND A GOOD NUANCED WAY TO KIND
OF LOOK AT PRESIDENT AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT WOULD WORK.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR.
CENTERED LIKE CLOTHES I WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
ON BEHALF OF NEGLECTED EMPLOYEES.
GIVING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY IN
FAIRNESS TO THE STATE.
AND OF THOSE EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU WITHOUT CENTER I DO
HAVE A OUR RECCO AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS BILL BEFORE I HOPE THEY
HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF THE
GOVERNOR JUST TURN AROUND.
AND I ALSO RECOMMEND AYE VOTES
WITH THAT SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
SB ONE SEVEN NINE DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIDE VOEPEL I WILL
TELL AYE CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER IPHONE.
FONG I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
WITH THAT SECTOR SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE NO THE AUTHORS PRESENT TO
GO AHEAD AND MOVE.
UP TO GET EMOTIONAL FOR THE
CONTENT [inaudible]
MOTION SECOND.
SECRETARY CALDERON CONSENT
CALENDAR OKAY.
WHERE SB ONE EIGHT FOR AN SB
SEVEN EIGHT TWO RODRIGUEZ?
MY BIGGEST SIGN PROPEL I WILL
TELL AYE CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG AYE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
IT IS ONE THAT WE WHICH IS
[inaudible]
THERE'S A
YEAH.
YEAH I WAS SECOND [inaudible]
IT WAS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
REALLY [inaudible]
YEAH.
SENATOR JUST IN TIME.
WE TRY TO BE RIGHT ON TIME ON
TOO LATE NOW PERFECT.
SO WITH THAT SENATOR HERE
PRESENT SB TWO SIX SIX QUIET YES
SIR GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
SB.
TWO SIXTY SIX PROTECTS THE
PROMISED AND PAID FOR RETIREMENT
BENEFITS OF CALPERS MEMBERS BY
MAKING SURE NO HARM COMES TO
RETIREE FOR ANY COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION.
THAT WAS REPORTED TO THE SYSTEM
THIS MEANS RISK THIS MAJOR
RESPONSE TO CASES IN WHICH
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION OF
RETIRED EMPLOYEES.
IS WRECKED OF RETROACTIVELY
DEEMED DISALLOWED BY CALPERS.
IN THESE INSTANCES THE RETIRED
EMPLOYEES ARE FORCED TO PAY BACK
THE TOTAL OVERPAID AMOUNT.
AND SUFFER PERMANENT REDUCTIONS
TO THEIR PENSIONS MANY RETIREES
RELY ON FIXED INCOMES AND SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
UNEXPECTED CUTS TO THEIR
BENEFITS.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
LONG AFTER THEY'VE MADE THE
DECISION TO RETIRE SB TWO SIXTY
SIX GIVES RETIREES LIVING ON A
FIXED INCOME PEACE OF MIND THAT
THE RETIREMENT THAT THEY HAVE
EARNED AND PAID FOR OVER A LIFE.
OF PUBLIC SERVICE WILL
CONSISTENTLY BE THERE THROUGHOUT
THE RETIREMENT YEARS.
THIS BILL COMPELS CALPERS AND
EMPLOYERS TO WORK TOGETHER TO
PROTECT RETIREE BENEFITS AND
PREVENT THESE INSTANCES FROM
EVER HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
SB TWO SIXTY SIX ALSO COMPELS
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP THEIR PROMISES
TO RETIREES AND HOLD THEM
HARMLESS FOR ANY REDUCTIONS TO
THE WRIST RETIREMENT.
AS A RESULT OF DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION HERE WITH ME AND
SUPPORT IS CHRISTY BELMONT.
AND BRANDY.
GO AHEAD MA'AM SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL.
WE THINK THE CENTER FOR BRING IT
BACK.
UP TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THAT
CAME TO LIGHT INITIALLY FOR US
WHEN THE CITY DAVIS FIREFIGHTER
SHE HAD WORKED FOR CITY OF DAVIS
WELL OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
RETIRED AND WAS FIVE YEARS INTO
HER RETIREMENT WHICH SHE GOT HER
LETTER FROM THE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM THAT SAID -- THE THE
COMPENSATION THAT WAS REPORTED
FOR YOU THAT WAS IN YOUR
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THAT WAS
CONSIDERED LONGEVITY PAY WHICH
IS.
SUPPOSED TO BE ALLOW WILL
BENEFIT ON THE SYSTEM THE
CALPERS OF THE EMPLOYER WAS MISS
A PLYING IT.
AND THEREFORE A CENTER LETTER
THAT SAID YOU NEED TO SEND US A
CHECK FOR FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WE WILL PERMIT THE
REDUCE YOUR PENSION FOR THE REST
OF YOUR PENSION WILL PERIOD AND
TO YOUR BENEFICIARY SO THIS BILL
JUST SIX TO PROTECT THAT RETIREE.
THE EMPLOYER IS OBLIGATED TO
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH.
A AND IN REPORT TO THE SYSTEM
AND CHECK WITH THE SYSTEM IF
THIS THIS AMOUNT OF THE ITEM OF
COMPENSATION WHETHER IT'S ON
JEOPARDY PAYER EDUCATIONAL SET
OF PAY.
HAZARD PAY E. M. T. PAY THESE
ARE ALL VALID PAY ITEMS BUT IT
IS UP TO THE EMPLOYER TO MAKE
SURE THEY FIT WITHIN THE
REGULATIONS OF THE SYSTEM.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THERE IS
SOME CONFUSION DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION IS JUST THAT IT IS
IN A CATEGORY A KNOWN CATEGORY
OF COMPENSATION TO CALPERS BUT
WITH RULES AROUND IT THE OFFER
TO THE SAME GROUP OR CLASS.
IS THAT ON A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
PAY SCHEDULE THOSE ARE ALL
EMPLOYER OBLIGATIONS I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
A CLERICAL ERROR WHERE A NUMBER
IS REPORTED THAT WAS INCORRECT
BECAUSE OF A MATHEMATICAL AIR
THERE'S A WHOLE BODY OF LAW
UNDER PURRS.
THAT HAND.
TELL THEM HOW TO HANDLE A
TYPOGRAPHICAL OR CLEAR CLEAR
ABOUT REPORTING COMPENSATION SO
THIS IS DISTINCT INTO DIFFERENT
BECAUSE IT WAS BARGAINED AND AS
OUR AUTHOR SAID IT WAS PAID.
FOR BY ALL PARTIES WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AGAIN TODAY.
MR MEMBERS RAINY PERIOD EVERY
DISSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF PORAC
IN HIGH PATROL CESSATION.
VERY SUPPORT OF CAN SEE MORE
CHRISTY JUSTICE.
THAT ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MORE MISTER MEMBERS RYAN CHARMER
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WERE CALPERS MEMBERS
AND WE STRONGLY ARCHER PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE'S PORT.
CA NINETY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
COMFORT.
YOUR FRIEND THERE'S PLENTY OF
ROOM.
IT'S GOT A BETTER SUIT ON THAT I
HAVE SO I GO HEAD -- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DATE
HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- RESPECT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE -- YOU
KNOW FIRST OFF.
AS AMENDED.
IT PUT PLACES A REAL BURDEN --
ON ON LOCAL AGENCY THAT SHIPS
1100% OF THE LIABILITY TO THE
EMPLOYER WITH REGARDS DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION WHEN THE BILL WAS
AMENDED.
IT REALLYPROVIDED A
DISINCENTIVE FOR CALPERS TO
ACCURATELY CALCULATE AND TO
ADMINISTER BENEFITS -- AS
GOVERNOR BROWN STATED IN HIS
VETO MESSAGE.
WE WANTED TO ENSURE HIS
SUGGESTION WAS THAT -- THAT
CALPERS THE REQUIRED TO REVIEW
EACH COP COP ANALYSIS TO ENSURE.
THAT TO WILL BE MUTUALLY AGREED
UPON BY BOTH LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT IT'S MINUTES PURRS
WAS IN FACT LAWFUL AND AND NINE
AND AND ALLOWED NOT DISALLOW
COMPENSATION WHEN THE BILL WAS
AMENDED OUT OF THE SENATE -- ALL
OF THAT LIABILITY I WAS TAKEN
AWAY FROM CALPERS AND REALLY
EVEN IF WE EXERCISE OUR OPTION
TO HAVE COOPER OF YOU CALPERS
CAN SIMPLY SAY YEP YOU'RE GOOD
TO GO AND THEN FIVE YEARS LATER.
SAY NEVER MIND WE MADE A MISTAKE --
IT IF IT IT WAS IN FACT I
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION.
THERE ARE NEARLY THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS ANDY CALPERS SYSTEM
SOME OF THOSE EMPLOYERS HAVE
DOZENS OF BARGAINING UNITS EACH
OF THOSE BARGAINING UNITS HAVE.
SOPHISTICATED TOURNEY'S UP BOTH
ON BOTH SIDES THAT MUTUALLY
AGREED TO THE BEST OF THEIR
UNDERSTANDING AS TO THE LAW AS
THEY INTERPRETED -- MUTUALLY
GRAHAM WHAT IS A CUT WHAT IS
DISALLOWED COMPLEMENT IS NOT TO
SLOW COP IT'S MEANT THAT TO
PURRS THERE NEEDS TO BE SOMEONE.
PURRS BEING THE ADMINISTRATOR
THE BENEFIT THAT IS THE STATUS
THE FAIL SAFE THE STOP GAP ON
WHAT IS ALLOWED TO WHAT IS NOT
ALLOWED AND I DON'T MEAN FIVE
YEARS LATER.
I MEAN THEY SHOULD DO A PRIOR TO
WHEN FOLKS ARE TIRED BECAUSE BE
AGREE THAT WHEN WHEN FOLKS
RETIRE THEY SHOULDN'T THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO YOU KNOW GET A
LETTER IN THE MAIL FROM HER
SAYING THAT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
REDUCING OR BENEFIT THAT IS.
CERTAINLY THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO -- IT THIS BILL TO BE
CLEAR YOU WILL REQUIRED LOCAL
AGENCIES TO CUT DIRECT CHECKS
FROM THEIR GENERAL FUNDS. TO
RETIRE REASON BUT AND
BENEFICIARIES IN PERPETUITY --
IT AS AS WELL AS THE STATE --
THAT WE'RE TALKING AFTER.
THE FACT THAT PERSON SAID THIS
IS A DISALLOWED BENEFIT THIS IS
NOT LAWFUL UNDER UNDER PEARL.
YOU LOCAL AGENTS YOU'RE GOING TO
BE CUTTING DIRECT CONTRIBUTION
CHECKS TO THESE PEOPLE FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES SO I JUST
AND WE JUST NEED TO MAKE THAT
VERY CLEAR.
AND THEY'RE STILL UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS WITH THIS BILL WITH
REGARDS TO RECIPROCITY AS WE
NOTED IN OUR IN OUR LETTER YOU
KNOW IF A IF A MEMBER WORKS FOR
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND IT WAS
THERE WAS DIVERSE YOU KNOW
PERHAPS DISALLOWED COMP.
THAT WAS ADDED YOU KNOW AGREE TO
OUT OF OUR AT OUR FORMER AGENCY
THEY WOULD YOU KNOW WHEN THAT
RETIRED WHEN THEY RETIRE.
UNDER RECIPROCITY CALPERS ISSUES
THAT SHOULD THE ISSUES THAT
BENEFIT UNDER THIS PARADIGM WHO
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR CUT FOR
CUTTING THAT CHECK WOULD BE THE
CITY THAT THE PERSON WORK FOR
WOULD BE THE CITY THAT THE
PERSON RETIRED FROM.
WE'RE NOT SURE -- ADDITIONALLY
THIS IS GONNA REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
GAS BE SIXTY REPORTING WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BE HIRING --
OUTSIDE ACTUARIES TO ASSESS WHAT
THOSE LIABILITIES ARE IN
PERPETUITY -- AND AGAIN YOU KNOW
WHAT WE E. I I KNOW WHAT THIS IS
EVERYONE'S FAVORITE ARGUMENT BUT
YOU KNOW THIS IS TO GIVE THE
PUBLIC FUNDS IT'S IT'S IN
VIOLATION THE CONSTITUTION IT'S
UNLAWFUL AND WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
ANYONE ELSE Là POSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BROUGHT
HOLD ON BEHALF OF PLASTER
COUNTING.
THIS ISSUE IS VERY REAL TO
PLASTER COUNTY AT THIS TIME.
OF PLACER COUNTY HAS ALSO
RECEIVED A DENIAL OF
COMPENSATION FROM CALPERS
REGARDING A LONGEVITY PROVISION.
BUT IN CONTRAST TO THE CITY OF
DAVIS PLASTER COUNTY HASN'T DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE ISSUE WITH
THIS PRESIDENT LEADS LEGISLATION.
WHO DETERMINES WHEN THE ACTUAL
THAT CITY OR THE LOCAL ENTITY IS
THE AGENT OF OF -- THE AIR THAT
CALPERS IS CALLING OUT AT FOUR
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION.
IN THE CASE OF PLASTER COUNTY
THE LONGEVITY PROVISION HAS BEEN
IN PLACE FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
PAYING INTO THIS LONGEVITY
PROVISION IT HASN'T CHANGED ONCE
WELL WHEN BET IT'S PLUS COUNTY
HAS UNDERGONE CALPERS AUDITS --
WE'VE PROCEEDED TO DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO DO IN
REGARDS.
TO THE LONGEVITY PROVISION.
MAKING PAYMENTS TO CALPERS
EMPLOYEES MAKING PAYMENTS TO
CALPERS AND THEN NOT UNTIL SO
FROM NINETEEN NINETY FOUR UNTIL
JUST IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EXCUSE
ME -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALPERS
CONSIDERED THIS PROVISION
COMPLETELY FINE.
NOW THEY'RE SAYING NO WE'RE
DISALLOWING IT'S DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN UNDER THIS LEGISLATION.
IT TAKES AWAY THE RIGHTS OF
PLASTER COUNTY.
AND ALL OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES TO
APPEAL THAT DECISION.
BECAUSE THE DECISION ONCE IT IS
MADE BY -- CALPERS VAN THAT
TRIGGERS ALL THE SUBSEQUENT
EVENTS THAT ARE DETAILED IN THE
LEGISLATION RIGHT NOW THERE'S AN
APPEAL PROCESS THAT WE'RE
UNDERGOING.
BUT BASED ON THE LEGISLATION AS
WRITTEN.
IF THE APPEAL PROCESS ISN'T
COMPLETED.
THE FOR THIS LEGISLATION IS IF
IT IS -- CONSIDERED AND SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR.
THE WE WOULD LOSE THAT APPEAL
PROCESS [inaudible]
SO.
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS ARE FROM
BEING DAMAGED BY THIS UP --
LEGISLATION.
INCREASED FINANCIAL RISK ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL PUBLIC
ENTITIES NOT JUST PLASTER COUNTY.
THIS IS A COMPLETE NEW PARADIGM
SHIFT FROM.
WHAT EXISTS NOW TO PUTTING THE
THE SOLE BURDEN ON THE LOCAL
ENTITY?
IT WOULD BE DRAMATIC WHEN YOU
CONSIDER NOT ONLY THE EXISTING
MEMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN PAYING
INTO.
THE ARM.
CALPERS FOR THIS PROVISION BUT
ALL OF THE RETIRED MEMBERS OVER
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
IT GOES TO THE ISSUE OF
SEPARATION OF POWERS THIS
LEGISLATION.
BASICALLY.
ORDERS THE LOCAL ENTITY TO MAKE
GOOD.
ON A PROVISION THAT HAS BEEN
TURNED DETERMINED BY CALPERS.
SHOULD BE DISALLOWED BALL.
SO IT IT AFFECTS IT'S IT'S NOT
ONLY ADDRESSES THE GOES TO THE
ISSUE OF GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
BUT IT GOES TO THE ISSUE OF
ACTUALLY ORDERING A PUBLIC
ENTITY TO COME UP WITH THE MONEY
AND MAKE GOOD.
BASED SOLELY ON THE DECISION OF
CALPERS SO [inaudible]
COM.
THE PROBLEM HERE.
IS THAT.
OVER THE YEARS AN INTERPRETATION
BY CALPERS.
CHANGES THEY WILL SAY OF THIS IS
GOOD AND THEN TWENTY YEARS LATER
THEY'LL SAY THIS IS BAD.
AND IF NOTHING HAS CHANGED NO
RULES HAVE CHANGED HOW IT HOW IS
THAT FAIR TO THE LOCAL ENTITIES
WHO FOR RELIED ON ALL OF THE
CIRCULAR LETTERS.
OF RELIED ON ALL OF THE MEETINGS
AUDIT EVERY TIME.
SOMEONE RETIRES THEY GO THROUGH
THESE PROVISIONS THEY GO THROUGH
THE ARM.
LONGEVITY PROVISION OR OR
WHATEVER PROVISION YOU YOU WOULD
CONSIDER [inaudible]
CAN AND EACH TIME IF IT'S
APPROVED IT REINFORCES WITH THE
LOCAL ENERGY.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEES BUT
YES THEY'RE GOING TO GET THE
BENEFIT AT THE END OF THE DAY
[inaudible]
MOST CERTAINLY.
INDIVIDUALS NEED TO HAVE.
FINANCIAL CLARITY FINANCIAL
CERTAINTY WITH THEIR PENSIONS.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
GOAL IS OF THIS PARTICULAR
LEGISLATION.
AND I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THE PARTICULAR OF
FIREFIGHTERS FROM THE CITY OF
DAVIS I REVIEWED THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE MATTER AND I KNOW
THAT IT'S STILL PENDING.
CALPERS HAS NOT FINALIZED THEIR
DECISION REGARDING THOSE TWO
INDIVIDUALS -- BUT I BELIEVE
THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO SOLVE
THIS AND A BETTER -- METHOD OF
ATTAINING THE GOAL.
THAT'S SOUGHT IN THIS PARTICULAR
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ELIZABETH WELL THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS WERE NOT -- WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION BASED ON THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT THIS WOULD HAVE
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
JEFF NEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
DOLE JOYS WITH PLASTIC COUNTY I
JUST WANT TO GET ON THE RECORD
THAT THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WE HAVE CONFIRMED WOULD COST US
AROUND SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
GOOD MORNING CARE ROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS IN
OPPOSITION.
DON'T GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION.
REMEMBER TRUST ABOUT THEM AT THE
SEA OF TECHNO WE APOLOGIZE WE
GET A LETTER IN BUT WOULD BACK
ARE CONCERNED WITH THE LEAGUE
THE VOICE.
WITH THAT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTION BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SOMEONE OUT ON WHAT YES THANK
YOU -- SO SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND
WHO WOULD BE THE BAD ACTOR IN
THIS EXERCISE SOMEONE GOES TO
APPLY FOR A BIG THE TURN OF THE
PAPERWORK THEY'RE GONNA RETIRE.
WAS IT CALPERS AT THE TIME THEY
DECIDED THEY WERE GOING TO
RETIRE AND DIDN'T CALCULATE THE
BENEFITS CORRECTLY SIMPLY DIDN'T
DIDN'T TELL THEM.
WHO WHO WHO WHO IS THE BAD ACTOR
HERE IF WE PLAY LACK OF A BETTER
TERM EMPLOYERS THE ONE WHO'S
MADE THE MISTAKE?
THEN IN THIS CASE DISTRICT IN
THIS SPECIFIC CASE FOR TIME AS
LONG IT WAS LONGEVITY.
SOMEHOW THEY DIDN'T.
I THOUGHT LONGEVITY DIDN'T COUNT.
SERVING THAT SAID IN A BAR IN
HIM FOR MANY YEARS AGO SB.
I'M JUST REFLECTS HELP LONGEVITY
WOULDN'T COUNT.
RIGHT SO YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE
CALPERS STATUTE AND REGULATION
THEY HAVE RULES.
GUIDING WHAT LONG JET WHAT
QUALIFIES FOR LONGEVITY PAY AND
AND WHAT WE'RE DISCOVERING WHEN
WE HEAR THESE THINGS AT THAT.
EMPLOYERS GET CREATIVE AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND MAYBE THEY
SAY THE LONGEVITY PAY -- IS
AFTER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
SERVICE AND THEN OVER GOING TO
TIE IT TO SOMETHING ELSE ALSO.
AND THAT IS NOT HOW LONG HAVE
ANY PAY IS AWARDED IT IS BASED
ON YOUR OWN TERMS SERVICE WITH
THE EMPLOYER AND AT ALL IT'S
OFFERED TO EVERYBODY WHO REACHES
THAT.
THRESHOLD WE'VE ALSO SEEN
EMPLOYERS TO SAY WILL BARGAIN
HAZARD PAY BUT WE DON'T WANT ANY
MORE THAN SIX PEOPLE EVER AT A
TIME. TO QUALIFY FOR THAT EVEN
THOUGH YOU MIGHT HAVE. TEN
FIREFIGHTERS THAT HAVE THAT
CERTIFICATION FOR FOR SOME HAS
MET SPECIALTY.
OKAY SO THEY'RE VIOLATING THE
WAY THEY'RE REAP THEIR REPORTING
IT.
IT'S CALPERS IT CATCHES IT AND
THEN DETERMINES SO THE TREATING
LIKE LONGEVITY PASSED LIKE
SPIKING.
WHEN IN FACT IT'S NOT SPIKING?
BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT IT WHEN THESE
AGREEMENTS ARE MADE THEIR MADE
SO BY.
VERY SOPHISTICATED TURNS ON BOTH
SIDES TO UNDERSTAND THE LAW AS
THEY BELIEVE IT IS INTERPRETED
WE SUBMIT THESE THESE MO USE OR
THESE THESE.
BOB.
THIS COMPETITION TO CALPERS WHO
AS WAS STATED BY -- PLASTER
COUNTY FOR YEARS HAVE SAID THAT
IT'S FINE AND THEN GO BACK AND
SAY WAIT NEVER MIND NO IT'S NOT.
IT'S A WE'VE BEEN GIVEN THE
GREEN LIGHT AS WE AGREE OF THESE.
AND THEN THEY GO BACK FIVE YEARS
LATER AND STATE YOU KNOW NEVER
MIND IN FACT I BELIEVE IN PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IN THE
CASE OF THE CITY DAVIS
FIREFIGHTER.
CREATED -- ACTUALLY SOUGHT A
COMPENSATION REVIEW FROM HERS
PRIOR TO RETIRING AND THEY SAID
YEP YOU ARE GOOD TO GO AND THEN
FIVE YEARS LATER.
THEY SAID WHOOPS NEVER MIND
YOU'RE NOT AND SO I YOU KNOW
THERE IS A EITHER TO SAY THAT
IT'S SOLELY THE EMPLOYER THAT IS
THE ARE THE BAD ACTOR ON THIS
ONE I I I I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S A MIS CHARACTERIZATION.
THAT'S WERE.
IN OKAY A COUPLE OTHER QUESTIONS
WITH REGARD TO THE THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT AYE AYE THE DATA I SEE
HERE IS ACTUALLY I WOULD ARGUE
SOMEWHAT MINIMAL.
BUT THEN I HEARD SOMEONE COME UP
IT'S A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ON THEIR ON THEIR ON THEIR
SINGLE COUNTY.
THE ONLY COMMON AND IT'S SO WHAT
I WOULD SAY HE SAID SIXTEEN
MILLION WHAT I WOULD SAY IS HOW
DOES HE KNOW DOES HE KNOW
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT THEY'RE NOT PAYING PROPERLY.
IF I COULD RESPOND. TO TWO
THINGS.
IN REGARDS TO THE IMMEDIATE
QUESTION.
UP THE SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
FIGURE COMES FROM A CALCULATION
OF HOW MUCH HAS BEEN CONTRIBUTED
TO CALPERS SINCE.
ON THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS IT
DIDN'T EVEN GO BACK TO NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR BY BOTH EMPLOYEES
AND THE EMPLOYER.
CALPERS CAN CLAW BACK THREE
YEARS WORTH OF A CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM MEMBERS AS IT EXISTS RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ALSO PURSUANT TO THIS
LEGISLATION THEY COULD GO BACK
TO EXISTING MEMBERS AND SAY HEY
GUESS WHAT.
WE'VE BEEN PAYING YOU THIS
PARTICULAR RETIREMENT BENEFITS
BENEFIT FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS BUT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
YOU A HAIR CUT NOW BECAUSE WE'VE
DECIDED NOW AFTER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
THAT IT YOU NO LONGER.
SHOULD DESERT YOU SHOULD RECEIVE
THIS LONGEVITY PAY.
SO THE THAT THE THE NUMBERS ARE
REAL.
AND THE WAY THE WAY THIS
LEGISLATION IS SET UP.
IT'S THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
COUNTIES THE CITIES THAT WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING GOOD
ON A DETERMINATION BY CALPERS.
BASED ON A NEW INTERPRETATION.
OF OF OF THEIR LONGEVITY
PROVISION THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN
IT'S NOT GOOD NOW WHY ALL OF A
SUDDEN ARE THERE NEW
INTERPRETATIONS WELL MAYBE IT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOOKING. FOR FOR
MONEY.
MAYBE THAT IS WHAT WHAT'S GOING
ON THE PROCESS IS.
WHEN SOMEONE RETIRES ALTHOUGH
CALPERS THEY DO AUDITS AND
THEY'VE DONE AUDITS OF PLASTER
COUNTY AND LONGEVITY HAS NEVER?
BEEN CALLED OUT THE PROCESS IS
FOR WHEN SOMEONE RETIRES.
THEY RECEIVE A REPORT FROM THE
LOCAL ENTITY AS TO WHAT IS THE
COMPENSATION AND IT'S BROKEN
DOWN AND DURING THAT TIME
CALPERS COMES UP WITH.
IN FACT I THINK THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE CITY OF DAVIS.
THE THE QUESTION WILL HOLD IT
WHY ARE YOU GETTING THIS
LONGEVITY LET'S LOOK AT THE
LONGEVITY.
AND AND IT IT IN THEIR MIND IT
DID NOT MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THEIR DEFINITION OF LONGEVITY.
HERE.
WE HAVEN'T CHANGED OUR LONGEVITY.
YOU HAVEN'T CHANGED CALPERS
HASN'T CHANGED YOUR DEFINITION
OF LONGEVITY NOTHING IS CHANGED
IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
WE'VE BEEN AUDIT.
YOU'VE REVIEWED THIS EVERY
SINGLE TIME SOMEONE HAS RETIRED.
THE HIGHER EARNERS WHEN THE
HIGHER EARNERS RETIRED THE THEY
DO MULTI MONTH.
INVESTIGATIONS THERE'S AN O. H.
DECISION THAT SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES THE PLASTER COUNTY --
LONGEVITY PROVISION AND IN THAT
CASE THEY DID NOT CONTEST THE
ARM THE LONGEVITY PROVISION BUT
NOW THE NOW OUT THERE TO
CONTESTING IT OKAY SO REAL QUICK.
JUST ONE REAL QUICK.
IT'S IT'S NOT BLACK AND WHITE IN
THE SENSE THAT YOU CAN PLACE ALL
OF THE BLAME ON THE EMPLOYER.
AND NONE OF THE BLAME ON CALPERS.
IT'S IT'S JUST NOT LIKE THAT IN
REALITY IT TELLS ME LIKE.
WE'RE WE'RE I'M HEARING THE WORD
LONGEVITY THE TERM LONGEVITY A
LOT SEEM LIKE THE PROBLEM IS THE
INTERPRETATION.
OF LONGEVITY I DON'T SEE HOW
CALPERS CAN EVER CONSIDER IT NOT
TO BE PART OF NORMAL
COMPENSATION WHEN IT'S ON THE
SCHEDULE ITS BARGAINING CENTER
BUT THAT.
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT WHITE BUT I
THINK THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
NECESSARILY HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY BUT AGAIN YOUR INTENT IS
THAT THIS APPLIES TO ALL PUBLIC
AGENCIES INCLUDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS CORRECT.
YES ECHO IT WILL IT WILL APPLY
TO CHARTERS CUTS OUT SALUTE IF
THAT'S NOT CLEAR WE WILL MAKE
THAT CLEAR OKAY THANK MY INTENT
WAS NEVER TO KEEP THEM I
UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND IT'S ONE
MAKE SURE BECAUSE YES.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY IF THEY'RE
NOT IN.
THAT EVERYONE.
AROUND IS TRUE AND THEN WE HAVE
A COURT -- SO -- WITH THAT I
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHO WOULD HAVE REQUIRED COMMA
THERE'S A CASE PLAYING ON A
SECOND COUNTY THAT GOES BACK TO
THE EIGHTIES A BENEFIT THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED?
AND WHAT HAPPENED IS A NEW --
RETIREMENT BOARD DIRECTOR COME
IN CO AND SAID NO THEY SHOULD
RECEIVE THESE BENEFITS SO HER
SUDDEN IT GOES BACK. THIRTY
SOMETHING YEARS AND NOW THEY'RE
CHANGING IT AND WHO GETS TO THE
IN THE EMPLOYEE DOES RETIREES.
SO IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE BOTH SIDES GO IN.
NEGOTIATED CONTRACTS YEAH
CALPERS I BELIEVE THIS GROUP
ONCE IN AWHILE.
BUT WHEN YOU KNOW YOU GET
NEGOTIATED CONTRACT YOU KNOW
ABOUT IT.
YOU HAVE YOUR ATTORNEYS THERE
AND IF SOMEONE NEGOTIATED THAT
CONTRACT THAT'S ON THEM ON
EITHER SIDE I MEAN SO IT'S IT'S
KIND OF HARD IN.
NO IT'S NOT LAST NIGHT WE GOT
SOME MOM LEADS WITH CITIES MY
LOCAL CITIES SENT ME LETTERS
OPPOSITION AT FIVE O'CLOCK LAST
NIGHT.
THAT'S B. S. IF YOU GOT A
PROBLEM.
HAVE THOSE FOLKS WAY IN EARLIER.
THE LEGAL AID INTO THE CITY'S
DIDN'T CELLS LIKE HEY.
IS THAT IMPORTANT TO YOU THAN
WAY IN EARLY THIS ISSUE.
AND A FIVE O'CLOCK LAST NIGHT
AND IT'S DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
BUT THE BIG ISSUE IS LIKE I SAID
I'VE SEEN PUT OUT ON BOTH SIDES.
I SIMPLY PROJECT NEGOTIATED AND
GOT NO WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU GO
INTO IT WITH WHAT EYES WIDE OPEN
SO.
THIS IS MY TWO CENTS WITHOUT
THAT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OFFER SOME ARTICLE IT'S I GUESS
I'M GONNA MOVE THE BILL BUT
THERE'S A DAY IN THIS AREA
GENERALLY AND I I'M I'M NOT
QUITE SURE HOW I WOULD.
FATHOM THE MEANING WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION.
SOLIS WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PENSIONS SYSTEM LIES WITH THE
RETIREMENT BOARD.
THIS INCLUDES A PAYMENT OF
BENEFITS IT'S ADMINISTRATION
[inaudible]
SO CONSTITUTIONALLY SOLIS WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE AS A PRUDENT EXPERT
BECAUSE THAT'S A STANDARD VOTERS
ADDED IN JUNE OF EIGHTY FOUR
UNITS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE
SPECIFICALLY IN THE CONSTITUTION
NOT RETIREMENT BOARD'S.
SO I SEE IS KIND OF DOING SOME
ADJUSTMENT BETWEEN.
THE RETIREMENT BOARD.
UNITS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT SOME
ALLOCATION OF WHO'S RESPONSIBLE.
BUT I SEE THE UNDERLYING
CONSCIOUS RAISES SAYS IT'S
RETIREMENT BOARD ITS SOLE AND
EXCLUSIVE INCLUDES
ADMINISTRATION -- SO I'M ALMOST
ONE IF THERE IS SOME.
WELL WHILE WE'RE TAKEN WITH THE
STATUTES WHETHER THIS.
UNDER GIRDING OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW. TO FIND WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
IN THE TOP.
THE EXTERNAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
THERE IS A SPECIFIC DEFINITION
THE CUSTOMS TO SAYS RETIREMENT
BOARD DOES NOT INCLUDE LOCAL
ELECTED.
SO I HI JUST ADMITTING THAT I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL HER TODAY.
BUT I EXACTLY HOW THIS WORKS IN
CONNECTION TO THE RELEVANT
CONSCIOUS PROVISION.
IS ACTUALLY SORT OF A QUESTION
MY MIND.
THANK YOU WITHOUT SAID ANOTHER
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SHE THE DISCUSSION -- BUT I JUST
WANT TO ALSO BE ON RECORD SAYING
THAT I COULD NOT DISAGREE MORE
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES THEY
WOULD HAVE YOU BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE IN THIS ACTUAL
SITUATION.
THERE ARE NOT THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE THIS AFFECTS
VERY FEW PEOPLE OUR HOPE IS IT
WILL NOT AFFECT ANOTHER PERSON
THIS BILL WOULD JUST MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A MECHANISM IN
PLACE SO THAT PERSON IS NOT
HARMED.
THE SIXTEEN MILLION.
I'D IF THAT IF THAT GENTLEMAN%
KNOWS THAT THEY THIS BILL COST
SOME SIXTEEN MILLION SINCE THEN
HE KNOWS THAT THEY ARE UNDER
PAYING PEOPLE AND THAT THEY HAVE
A PROBLEM SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
FIX IT NOW FIX IT YOU DON'T NEED
THIS BILL TO FIX THAT PROBLEM.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I DO HAVE A
AN AYE RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
AND I THINK THAT IN THE DAY WE
NEED TO PROTECT OUR PRESIDENT
FUTURE RETIREES AS IN FORT.
SO THAT SECTOR WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
HAVE A SECOND WITHOUT SURGERY
CALDERON.
HE MOTIONS TO PASS TO TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I VOEPEL.
WELL I CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
AYE.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG AYE O'DONNELL THANK.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU
.
SENATOR WILL THEY DIDN'T SEE YOU
COME FORWARD.
THE MOVE THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT HE'S HERE TO PRESENT
PHONE NUMBER SIX THAT'S J. R..
THREE WE LIKE TO SEE ALL RIGHT
CENTER.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU'RE READY IN
THE P..
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION THREE
URGES CONGRESS TO DO SOMETHING I
SHOULD HAVE DONE A LONG TIME AGO
WHICH IS REPEAL THE GOVERNMENT
PENSION OFFSET ALSO KNOWN AS THE
GPO.
AND THE WIND POLLINATION
PROVISION WEB -- THESE ARE TO
FEDERAL POLICIES THAT WHILE
PERHAPS WERE WELL INTENTIONED
APPROVING TOTALLY UNFAIR TO MANY
PUBLIC SERVANTS THESE UPDATED
POLICIES ARE HAVING A DENTAL
EFFECT ON MANY HARD WORKING A
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SUCH TEACHERS.
FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IF AN IMP IF AN
EMPLOYEE HAS WORKED IN BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE SECTORS.
THEY MAY HAVE PAID INTO BOTH SO
SECURITY AND A SEPARATE
GOVERNMENT PENSION.
IN THE CASE IF THIS IS THE CASE
THE WEAPONS SLASH AT PERSONS
RIGHTFULLY EARNED SO SECURITY BY
AT LEAST HALF.
I HAVE A FRIEND WHO'S A
FIREFIGHTER FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS
AND HIS SOUL SECURITY.
SLASH BY 90%.
YEAH THE JEEP THE GPO IS SIMILAR
IF SOMEONE IS PAID IN FULL
SECURITY AND THEIR SPOUSE HAS
PAID INTO SEPARATE GOVERNMENT
PENSION THEY KNOW SO SECURITY
BENEFITS ARE IN DANGER AS WELL.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY NOT FAIR
THERE'S NO REASON THE THESE
PEOPLE SHOULD GET BACK THEY
SHOULD GET BACK EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'VE PAID INTO.
SO THIS IS SPECIALLY HARMFUL TO
LOW INCOME WORKERS WHO ARE
ALREADY A DISADVANTAGE.
AND WHO RELY ON THESE BENEFITS
AFTER THEY RETIRE.
AND MANY PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW
IT UNTIL RIGHT BEFORE THEY
RETIRE.
WHICH CAN CAUSE EXTREME
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FOR THOSE WHO
DO KNOW BEFOREHAND THESE
POLICIES WILL DISCOURAGE HIM
FROM PURSUING BADLY NEED PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT.
LIKE TEACHING A PARTICULAR AIM
CONCERNED ABOUT STEM EDUCATION
AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT SO THIS
MAKES IT HARDER FOR OUR COUNTRY
TO COMPETE ON AN AT
INTERNATIONAL SCALE.
SO IT'S WELL PAST TIME THAT THE
CONGRESS DO THE RIGHT THING AND
REPEAL BOTH THE GPO AND WEPT.
AND ASK FOR AYE VOTE AND I WILL
ALLOW YOU TO SELF THAN EVERYBODY
THERE IS NO ISSUE THAT LIGHT IS
OFTEN A PIE AND AND TESTIFIED
SUPPORT THANK YOU GO AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION -- THIS HAS
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
TEACHING POPULATION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA 72% OF WHICH ARE
WOMEN AND WE'VE MADE IT --
EDUCATIONAL POLICY OVER THE LAST
FEW DECADES TO SPECIFICALLY RY
TO RECRUIT RETAIN TEACHERS AS A
SECOND CAREER SPECIFICALLY IN
STEM BUT THE DIRTY LITTLE SECRET
IS THAT WE HAVEN'T TOLD THEM
CAST WHAT BY SERVING THE KIDS IN
OUR STATE.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
PENALIZED WHEN YOU RETIRE WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET CONGRESS. TO
CHANGE THESE ACTIONS FOR A FEW
DECADES NOW UNFORTUNATELY
WITHOUT ANY RESOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE ON WHICH PARTICULAR REALLY
HARMFUL I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY TO STRESS PHONE CALLS I GET
FROM RETIREES -- ALMOST ALL OF
THEM ARE WOMEN IN THEIR
SEVENTIES EIGHTIES NINETIES
WHOSE SPOUSES JUST PASSED AND
THEN THE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS THAT THEY WERE RELYING
UPON -- WHEN THEIR SPOUSE PASS
THEY FIND OUT ARE GOING TO BE
EITHER REDUCE OR COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED AND IN THAT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THIS HAS
ON WOMEN WHO?
STATISTICALLY LIVE LONGER THAN
MEN HAVE BEEN RELIANT UPON THE
INCOME THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
JUST HAVE IT RIPPED OUT FROM
THEM IS ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING
UP FOR OUR POPULATION AND SINCE
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE TO LIVE IN
OUR STATE.
THAT THEN HAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IN IS LEADING TO A LOT OF
THESE ELDERLY WOMEN BEING ON THE
BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS SO THE
SOONER THAT WE CAN GET CONGRESS.
TO TAKE ACTION ON THIS ISSUE THE
SOONER THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A MORE STABLE ISIS SENIOR
POPULATION.
AND THAT'S MY CLUB.
I WAS GOOD.
WITH THE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
A MATURE MEMBERS PATRON WITH
THEIR AND RE DISSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE RETIRED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS -- BACK IN
CONGRESS FOR DECADES RIGHT GET
THIS REPEALED -- AND WE LIKE
ASSOCIATE HERSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS ALREADY MADE AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT HI GOOD
MORNING MARIANNE ACTUALLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM WERE ALSO VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE.
SEEN ON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTION BY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
MEMBERS -- SOME REMEMBER
O'DONNELL.
IT'S THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING --
THIS ITEM FORWARD AND I
UNDERSTAND AS A TEACHER I
UNDERSTAND ITS IMPORTANCE --
BASICALLY I GET PENALIZED IRON
SOCIAL SECURITY IN SOME OF THE
EARLY YEARS IN FACT A MORNING IT
NOW RIGHT.
YET I PROBABLY WON'T BE ABLE GET
IT RIGHT BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT I HAVE.
A GOVERNMENT PENSION BUT ONLY
FOR THAT TIME WHEN I WHEN I
SERVED AS A TEACHER I THINK YOUR
YOUR POINT THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
WITH REGARD TO PEOPLE.
ENTERING THE TEACHING
PROFESSIONAL PROFESSION LATER IN
LIFE IS A GREAT ONE BECAUSE I'VE
ACTUALLY HEARD OF PEOPLE WANT TO
GO INTO TEACHING.
AND THEN THEY LEARN ABOUT THE
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA LOSE THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
ESSENTIALLY -- AND IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT DISINCENTIVE FOR MID
CAREER INDIVIDUALS GOING TO THE
TEACHING PROFESSION AND BRING
THAT.
THAT EXPERTISE THEY HAVE SO
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTION BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE NONE SENATOR LIKE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT I BELIEVE WE DON'T WAS
A MOTION WITH THEIR SECOND.
MOTION AND SECOND.
AND I DO HAVE IN IRAQ WHEN I
THINK IT'S ALL BEEN SAID WHY
WITH THAT'S SECTOR LIKE CALDERON.
IN MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
RODRIGUEZ.
OUR GUESTS AYE VOEPEL RIGHT
VOEPEL AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY HI COOLEY
NAY COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THE MEASURES OUT SEVEN NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
ALL IN WITH THAT I THINK WE HAVE
A COUPLE ITEMS ON CALL I THINK
US SECRETARY WANT TO GO WITH THE
NAME MISSING MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR START THE FIRST.
CALL THE MISSION MEMBERS.
CONSENT CALENDAR SB ONE EIGHTY
FOUR IN SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES HI.
CONSENT COLORS OUT SOME UNKNOWN
AND LET'S GO BACK.
TO OUR FIRST FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB ONE SEVENTY NINE NELSON
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
COMMITTEE ON TO DISH.
US CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE.
NEXT ONE OF FAR NUMBER THREE SB
TWO SIX SIX US SECRETARY CALL
THE MISSION MEMBERS -- WHAT'S
THE RETURN ACTION.
WITHOUT THE BELIEVE WE HAVE.
DONE ALL OF OUR ISSUES FOR TODAY
AND THAT COMES TO AN FOR OUR A
MEETING.
ON PURSE THANK EVERYBODY FOR
INNER